Capcom go there was a scripted moment
when the character was supposed to break
down and when we got to it we felt
forced and Ridley and I kind of looked
at each other and were like this doesn't
feel right does it
look man we shopped stuff with the other
actors months earlier but they'd all
gone home and Ridley and I had made all
those scenes just together where it was
just me on camera recovery
and so suddenly I heard in my helmet as
the gimbal starts to shudder as if this
thing is going to take off and the light
effects start to happen and like and you
really feel like you're about to kind of
take off and suddenly I heard the voices
of all of these actors who were my
buddies you know secondary recovery go
and it dawned on me you know thinking
through the kind of the filter of this
character like he hadn't heard a voice
in a year and that these people had made
this sacrifice to come back for him
pilot
go it just totally happened and it
wasn't planned that's just great
directing that's Ridley just kind of put
a move on me I didn't see it come